My name is Rumen Hristov,
and I'm supervised
by Professor Dina Katabi.
Device-free sensing has enabled
a variety of systems for health
monitoring in people's homes.
Our device in
particular is a sensor
that you attach on the
wall and emits RF signals.
Based on the way these
signals are reflected,
we can localize
the people and see
whether they're walking, they're
just sitting, or laying in bed.
However, one issue with this is
that we don't know who is who.
If there are two people
in the environment--
Bob and Anna-- and one
of them is sleeping
and the other one
is walking, we don't
know whether the person who is
walking is Bob or it is Anna.
And this is exactly the problem
that my research is solving.
One major challenge
with this is that we
need to obtain ground root
label data in people's homes.
We can't just put cameras
and see what's going on
and who is who because they
have a big privacy concern.
And our solution is to give
the small accelerometer
sensor to the person
that we're monitoring.
And we correlate the motion
from the accelerometer sensor
with the output of our device.
In this way we obtain
label data in the homes.
However, the people
wear this sensor
only for just a couple of days.
And after that,
we're on our own.
Fortunately, people
reflect the RF signals
in a unique way based on their
body shape or their height.
So we leverage this information
and build the neural network
using the information that we
got from these couple of days
when we have labeled data.
And we manage to
then find people only
based on the way they
reflect RF signals.